yes ah hi there I'm The Legend of Zelda
series producer Eiji Aonuma you may have
already heard about it during bethesda
showcase that was held a few days ago it
was announced that select Zelda items
will appear in the Nintendo switch
version of Skyrim I'm really looking
forward to exploring Skyrim with the
master sword in hand oh when did this
Master Sword get in my hand next up
we'll take a look at the DLC packs for
the Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
let us take you on a new Hyrule
adventure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
what did you think I actually have one
more announcement that I'd like to share
the four champions that appeared in the
Legend of Zelda breadth of the wild will
be available as amiibo the zora champion
meifa the Goron champion diruk the rito
champion Ravalli and the Gerudo champion
herb osa you'll be able to use these
four amiibo in the Legend of Zelda
breadth of the wild of course you'll be
able to use these in the DLC packs that
you just saw so please look forward to
them this